c'est un lieu où on offre des migrants
enceintes accompagnement et sécurité
parce que derrière ces sourires ces
femmes portent les souvenirs d'un long
et pénible voyage
c'était vraiment terrible haïtienne
Géraldine et Daphné ont toutes deux
d'abord migrés vers le Chili pour
ensuite traverser les trois Américains
un parcours de plus d'un an à travers
une dizaine de pays
jusqu'à arriver au Mexique
tu n'as pas de papier
pas de papier peu de moyens pas de
protection un parcours parsemé de
violence et de discrimination parce que
à cause de ma colère vous pensez quand
vous êtes noir surtout haïtien il y a
quelque chose qui me passait au Mexique
avant d'arriver ici
et je veux pas parler
[Musique]
Géraldine n'est pas seul la portée les
blessures de la migration pas de prise
de sang et après tout selon parcours
nous on les on les prend les accueille
et
c'est lourd
l'état appelle les accouchements des
demandeuses de statut de réfugiés et ici
on offre l'accompagnement avant la
grossesse nous on fait le suivi de
grossesse gratuitement donc ça nous
permet c'est pour ces femmes là ça leur
permet d'avoir un suivi de grossesse
s'assurer qu'elles sont en santé
le suivi se poursuit après
l'accouchement
aujourd'hui Amélie la marche rencontre
le petit dernier de la famille El Sayed
abassane égyptien d'origine ils ont fui
le Koweït où il s'était établi le
nouveau-né est très calme sa croissance
se déroule bien c'est un engorgement
probablement est-ce que tu as fait de la
fièvre avec une interprète l'équipe
conseil la jeune maman
ils m'ont beaucoup aidé pour m'aider à
savoir comment m'occuper de lui il monte
aussi offert une aide matérielle parce
que son fils est né en décembre au
Québec ses parents l'ont baptisé Noël un
mot qui symbolise pour eux l'espoir de
demeurer ici mais
maintenant c'est son pays et son frère
va déjà à l'école à Montréal du Mohamed
l'augmentation du nombre de migrants qui
arrivent au Québec se répercute ici
seulement sur l'île de Montréal le
nombre de demandeuses d'asile enceintes
prise en charge par l'État et passer de
51 en mars à 101 en novembre ici elle
représente maintenant la majorité de la
cinquantaine de femmes suivies en
pédiatrie sociale un défi pour
l'organisme surtout que les demandeurs
d'asile peinent à travailler parce que
les permis sont livrés au compte-goutte
par Ottawa
du coup ces personnes là ont l'aide
sociale c'est 1200 par mois et il peint
loyer à 1100 donc il reste 100 dollars
des fois ils ont déjà un enfant ou deux
je vous laisse imaginer
mais dans les preuves l'accompagnement
offert par l'organisme remonte le moral
des migrants
il y a Camille il y a Cindy oh il y a
beaucoup de personnes c'est vraiment
et ce matin on annonce une bonne
nouvelle elle m'a autorisé à vous
l'annoncer elle a reçu sa résidence
permanente
c'est ce que toutes ces femmes attendent
obtenir le statut de réfugiés pour
demeurer ici avec leur enfant canadien
parce que tu ne sais pas qu'est-ce qui
va arriver simplement dieu le sait ici
David